ETHAN: Your fingers
freeze up and get cold.
And they feel like you've got
a glove on even when you don't.
It becomes almost impossible
to do some of the things
you've got to do.
I'm handling metal
with bare hands.
MAN 1: Put it in your mouth.
And then it warms up.
Is that a trick?
Yeah.
Well, I don't really
want to lose the nuts
and washers in the
snow, so I've just
been putting them in my mouth.
But they're a bit cold, so
I've been ripping bits of skin
off my tongue with them.
Whoa!
Oh, that one's really cold.
[music playing]
Cool.
Shall we put it up?
CHRISTIAN: Yes.
[grunting with effort]
MAN 1: Easy, now!
CHRISTIAN: Yup, it's heavy.
Hopefully this
weather station will
become a part of
helping us understand
what's going on here.
Once we get a few
storms through,
hopefully it'll give
us some good data.
There it is!
Woo-hoo!
[plane zooming]
WOMAN 1: Woo!
CHRISTIAN: It's a huge
relief to be done setting up.
Now we have our base
camp for future seasons.
We've figured out
what we needed to.
Everything worked the
way it should have.
We showed that, you know,
the Ross Ice Shelf program
works really, really well.
We have scientists from
all different disciplines
all coming together.
Whatever we're going to
discover, it's going to be new.
And it's going to
be interesting.
[snowmobile zooming]
MAN 2: We need muscles!
MAN 3: OK, good.
Get that shovel!
MAN 1: So we're going
to stage some stuff
here for the following season.
So we've left 50-odd
drums of fuel over there.
Next year, we'll be coming
straight back out to this side.
And we'll have kind of the basis
of the camp already set up.
Here's poo, some
of our food waste,
recycling, and
our general waste.
We'll get rid of a
fair bit of that.
Pees!
Lovely.
[grunting with effort]
[laughing] Your favorite
part of your job, I bet.
The Scott Base, they
can only process one
of those pee barrels every day.
So we'll go home with 34.
So we wanted to get as many as
we can back to Scott Base now
to start that process.
It's going to take a month to
get rid of our pees from here.
We don't need snacks.
How long's the flight?
An hour?
Yeah, an hour.
MAN 1: Basically, it will
take away four of our people,
leaving us with a
little small crew
to begin the return journey.
WOMAN 2: What is this
luxury accommodation?
MAN 1: I know.
All-- all this
space on our feet.
WOMAN 2: Those rookies!
MAN 4: Momma, I'm coming home!
[laughter]
[music playing]